تشبه كتير وقفت قدامكم هلا ولكن كانت قدام
طلاب الصيدله السنه الخامسه باول محاضره
لالي
لحتى ما اعرف عن حالي قلبي بسرعه
وكل شي كان عم يدور ببالي هو شو ممكن تكون
انطباعا
لحظه هل يا ترى برايكم لحظه تكفي لحتى
ياخذوا فكره عني اكيد لانه عشره ثانيه
بكفي ولكن لما تكون هاي الافكار عم تحطني
بقالب معين بناء على شكلي على لبسي بناء
على عمري على اسم عيلتي او حتى المكان
اللي بنسمي لاله فبارحاله فينا نقول انه
هالافكار مو بس ممكن تكون غير واقعيه ولكن
هي الافكار كمان ممكن تكون مؤذيه وغير
عادله لالي
مرحبا اسمي نور جبيله صيدلانيه واليوم جاي
وحابه احكي لكم عن تجربتي
صراحه اي حدا بهداك الموقف كان واقف محلي
كان بشوف بعيون الطلاب نظره قله الخبره
والكفاءه لالي والسبب
والسبب الصراحه انه شكلي اوقات بعض
الاحيان ما بيبين علي العمر بس دقولي على
الخشب
هالنوع هذا من التفكير مثل ما بيعرف
اغلبكن اسمه التفكير النمطي او الستيريو
النمطي اللي احنا عم نحكي عنه حاليا هو
تفكير جدا مزعج ومستفز طيب هذا النوع من
التفكير راح تستغربوا هلا وقت اخبركن عن
اصل الكلمه كلمه السر بالاساس كانوا
يستخدموها لحتى يوصفوا الطباعه باستخدام
الاحرف المعدنيه القاسيه مثل ما انكم
شايفين ليصير بعدين مصطلح الستيريو تايبين
مستخدم من قبل علماء النفس بعد 1922 لحتى
يوصفوا فيه الطريقه اللي بيستخدمها دماغ
الانسان ليصنف العالم ضمن قوالب معينه
والزعم فيها بغض النظر عن فرديتهم او حتى
ميزاتهم
طيب هلا عم نقول انه تفكير النمطي هو مزعج
ومستفز احيانا ولكن مع الاسف كل البشر
تستخدموا وهذا الشيء بخلينا على طول
نتساءل شو السبب اللي بخلينا نعتمد على
هالنمط هذا المزعجه من التفكير
بدي مقاله نشرتها مجله جامعه اوكسفورد
بتاكد انه تفكير النمطي هو تفكير بيساعدنا
لحتى نفهم العالم بطريقه اوضح كيف يعني عن
طريق التعميم
والطعميهم تعميم المعلومات وتبسيطه طيب
تعميم التبسيط هذا بساعدنا لحتى نحفظ
المعلومات بسهوله اكتر مو بس هيك كمان
بساعدنا نتنبا بالمجهول يعني فينا نقول
انه اجدادنا بفضل نمطيه قدروا يعرفوا انه
النباتات السامه شكلها هيك وقدروا يعرفوا
انه الحكمه هيك
مؤذيه والهريبه تلتين المراجل
طور معنا شوي شوي تفكير النمطي لحتى يشمل
المجتمعات البشريه وارتبطت الصور النمطيه
بشكل كثير كبير بالانتماء وصلنا نقصن
حالنا نحن البشر ضمن مجموعات معينه صرنا
مثلا عرق اسود عرق ابيض عرق اسيوي صرنا
سكان دول العالم ثالث وثاني واول صرنا
نساء مسؤوله عن البيت ورجال بمواقع السلطه
مو بس هيك حتى بالبلد الواحد صرنا سكان
مدينه متحضرين وسكان ريف بدائيين وصلنا
اذا بنشوف سياره ماشيه بشكل مكركب على
الطريق شو بنقول اكيد الي عم بتسوقها مراه
او امراه للاسف
[موسيقى]
الايجابيه لحسن الحظ هي سبب الرئيسي
لسمعنا العبارات رنانه مثل ليش ما بدكم
مثل ابن خالتك او ليش مانك هني بالدراسه
مثل اخواتك طيب بس انا الصراحه نسيت اقول
لكم شغله ان النمطيه ممكن يكون الى
ايجابيات والى ايجابيه مهمه جدا جدا لان
كلنا واللي هي الضحك على نكت الحماصنه
وغيرهم صح نسيت اخبركم محسوبتكم من حمص
كلياتنا بنتفق او ما حدا فينا راح يستغرب
اذا قلنا النمطيه هي بشكل عام الا سلبيات
عديده لانه كل حدا فينا اكيد مرق عليه
موقف ونحط ضمن قالب نمطي معين
وبناء على هذا امرات كثيره اكيد بالمدرسه
وبالشغل باي مكان بالمجتمع وبناء على
هالشي هذا رح اطلب هلا من كل حدا فيكم
يحاول يتذكر مره واحده بس نحط فيها ضمن
قالب نمطي معين او صندوق نمطي تذكر شو كان
شعورك وقتها شو حسيت
حسيت بالاحباط حسيت بالحزن
ممكن حسيت بالخجل الظلم
ممكن حسيت بالتوتر بالدونيه او ممكن حسيت
بالغضب
طيب وشو حسيت بمره كنت انت خير الشخص اللي
عم بينوم الاخر حسيت بالدم او حسيت
بالفوقيه
طبعا اكيد هالمشاعر اللي عم نحكي عنها
كلياتها هي مشاعر سلبيه هالمشاعر السلبيه
هي كفيله انه هي تقطع التواصل او تبعدني
عن الاخر حتى لو كانت حتى لو كنا انا
والاخر قراب كتير من بعض وبيناتنا علاقه
ثقه هالمشاعر هاي كفيله انه تبني حاجز
كبير بيني وبين الاخر وتجعل التواصل
بيناتنا شبه مستحيل وبتاكد نظريه روزنبرغو
ان النمطيه دائما بتدفعنا لحتى تشكل مشاعر
اتجاه الشخص الاخر
نتصرف بسلوك معين ممكن يتحول لتحيز ضد هذا
الشخص وبالتالي اكيد راح نشكل افكار تجاه
هذا الشخص وعلى الاغلب اكيد راح تكون
افكار سلبيه وافكار مؤذيه له طبعا ما
بخفيكن هذا السبب او هالشي هذا عم نحكي
عنه ممكن تكون سبب لانخفاض علامات ومعدلات
بعض الطلاب بعض الطلاب اللي خلوا نمطيهم
اللي درستهم الفصل اللي حكيت لكم عنه بعد
الطلاب اللي خلوا النمطيهم عني تاثر عليهم
وتمنعهم يستفيدوا من المعلومات اللي عم
بعطيهم اياها من كل قلبي يعني بالنهايه
خلينا نحط حالنا محلهم مين فينا راح يتعلم
من استاذ اذا كان شايفه قليل الخبره اكيد
ولا حدا وما بنسى انه هاي المشكله هي
المشكله منتشره بشكل كثير كبير بجامعاتنا
بمدارسنا ومنتشره كمان ببيئات العمل
طبعا المشكله هاي عم تمنع الطلاب
والموظفين انهم يستفيدوا من الخبرات
والمعلومات اللي عم تتقدم لهم والسبب هو
صورهم النمطيه عن اساتستون وعن مشرفينهم
طيب وقت اللي بنكون نحن الاشخاص المنظمتين
يعني الصوره النمطيه عم بتكون علينا
بهالحاله طبعا النمطيه راح توقعنا بدائره
من توتر والالاء لا الثقه بالنفس وبالتالي
ضعف الاداء والانجاز الدائره هاي اللي عم
بحكيلكم عنا اسمها تحديد النمطيه او
الستريو تايب الدائره هاي او تهديد
النمطيه ينعمل عنه كتير دراسات واشهرهم
دراسه تمت عام 2008 على 157 طالب وطالبه
جامعيين من المتفوقين الرياضيات طبعا هاي
الدراسه كان هدف الرئيسي كان هدف الرئيسي
لالها انه تدرس الصور او تاثير الصور
النمطيه عن الاناث انهن اقل كفاءه
بالحسابات الرياضيه المعقده
طبعا تمت الدراسه على مرحلتين باول مرحله
قالوا فيها للمشاركين والمشاركات انه
هالمرحله هاي بتميز بين قدره الذكور
والاناث بحل الحسابات الرياضيه
في المرحله الثانيه فقبل ما يبلشوا خبروهم
انه الكل قادر يحل هالاختبار بنفس الكفاءه
وهون كانت الصدمه
قدر تهديد النمطيه انه يؤثر على اداء
المشاركات باول مرحله من الاختبار وكانت
نتائج او ما قدروا يحصلوا على المعدلات
نفسها يحققوها المشاركين باول مرحله
بالرغم من انه نتائج كانت نفسها تماما
بالمرحله الثانيه باختبار طبعا هالشي اللي
عم بحكيلكم عنه اللي هو تاثير تهديد
النمطيه كلياتنا وكل حدا فينا نختبره
بحياته ولكن بطريقه مختلفه واختبرته انا
شخصيا
بالتوتر قبل التحضير لكل محاضره هداك
الفصل حكيت لكم عنه
هالخبره هاي طبعا بعد ما حكينا كل
هالسلبيات هاي عن النمطيه اكيد كل حدا
فيكم هلا صار مقتنع انه انه منطيه مستحيل
انه يكون مجتمع مبني علي او يكون مجتمع
مبني عنها مطيه اذا اذا بدنا اياه يكون
مجتمع متنوع متنوع باختلافات افراده وهذا
الشيء اللي شفناه بشكل كتير واضح بفتره
الازمه ببلدنا سوريا لما بلشت تسيطر الصور
النمطيه عبر وسائل الاعلام وانتشرت افكار
نمطيه قديمه هالافكار هاي النتيجه الظروف
والازمه الصعبه اللي مرينا فيها والنتيجه
كانت للاسف انه ابتعدنا عن اشخاص بنحبهم
ومصطفيهم
ان تحطيم الذره اسهل بكثير من كسر النمطيه
والتحيز
فعلا لانه بالوقت اللي بيتطلب فيه تشكيل
صوره نمطيه عن الاخر جزء من الثانيه يتطلب
وقت بالايام وخبرات ومواقف كثيره لاقدر
اكسر هالصوره النمطيه بتشكلت عن الاخر
طبعا فعليا فيني اقول لكم اني استهلكت
الفصل الدراسي كاملا لحتى قدرت اكسر
هالصوره النمطيه اللي شكلوه عن الطلاب
باول ثانيه من الفصل
التجربه هاي اللي كانت جديده علي علمتني
وخلتني فكر شو فيني اتصرف بمواجهه النمطيه
هاي مو بس مع الطلاب برجعوا اكيد معي شخص
ممكن يقابله بالمجتمع
بعد التفكير تبين معي انه ممكن بيمشي
الحال لحتى او بيمشي الحال اذا حطيت حالي
محل الاخر حاولت تحس بمعاناته اسمعوا عن
جد حاولت تحس بالمشاعر اللي عم يمرق فيها
انا يمكن بحاجه لمطرقه كثير كبيره لحتى
اقدر اكسر هذا الحاجز اللي شكلته النمطيه
بيني وبين الاخر
وهالمنطرقه بدون شك هي التعاطف
لتجربه كتير مميزه لالي كانت مع منظمه
عالميه بورشه تدريبيه
سوريين ولبنانيين مثل شايفين
بهالاجتماع هاد كنا عم نناقش الصور
النمطيه اللي انتشرت خلال فتره اللجوء
بالازمه السوريه واكيد كلكم عارفين
تتذكروا
طبعا بوقتها ما تتصوروا الراحه النفسيه
اللي حسينا فيها بمجرد ما كل طرف حكى عن
معاناته من الاحكام والافكار النمطيه
المغلوطه سمع الطرف الثاني عن جد سمعوا
بعمق وقدر يحس بشعوره ومعاناته
والنتيجه اللي كانت شايفين تجربه مميزه
جدا مع اشخاص مميزين مميزين جدا ما بنساهم
ابدا
طبعا التعاطف حسب مقالب بعنوان
او علم التعاطف عام 2007 بتاكد هالمقاله
انه التعاطف له دور اجتماعي كتير كبير
ومهم لانه بيساعدنا لحتى نتبادل الرغبات
والخبرات مو بس هيك كمان بعزز التواصل
وبعزز الحوار بالاضافه لهذا الشيء بتشبهوا
المقاله بجسر عاطفي الجسر هذا بيزيد من
السلوك الاجتماعي الايجابي مثل الخدمه مثل
مثل اللطف مثل المشاركه وهي الاشياء اللي
نحن بامس الحاجه لالها وخاصه بعد فتره
الازمه القاسيه اللي عدت على بلدنا
طبعا التعاطف اكيد مثل ما كنا بنعرف مان
عمليه سهله ولكن لحسن الحظ دماغنا وجهازنا
العصبي مصمم انه هو يقوم بهالعمليه
المعقده بسهوله
وبقاء مثل ما بتاكد المقاله نفسها بتاكد
انه بقاء الجنس البشري ما بيعتمد مثل ما
كنا مفكرين من زمان على قانون الغاب او
البقاء للاقوى لا وانما بيتركز على
التعاطف فهم معاناه الاخرين الشعور بالالم
وفهمه والدليل هو دراستنا لتاريخ حياه
الانسان ابتداء من المجتمعات القبليه
والبدائيه جدا واللي بيتميز او بتتميز
بوجود التعاطف والشعور بالالم عند الاخر
اكثر من محاولات السيطره او حتى القضاء
عليه
تعاطف هو مهاره
فينيميها فيني يدربهم وحتى فيني يساعد
غيري لحتى يستخدمه او ينمو شعورهم
بالتعاطف بشكل اكبر
خلينا مثلا بالمره اللي جايه بدل ما احكم
على زميلي بالشغل انه هو افكاره قديمه وما
بيعرف يستخدم وسائل التواصل خليني مثلا
احاول احط حالي محله حاول اسمعه عن جد
بدون ما احكم عليه او اشفقوا عليه
وبهالحاله ساعتها طبعا ممكن المره اللي
جايه لنقعد فيها مو بس انه نحن نتحاور
ممكن نتحاور ويعطيني من خبرته لحتى ازيد
انتاجيتي
خلونا مثلا بدل ما نتعامل مع اولادنا
اخواتنا وبناتنا الصغار على اساس انهم من
هذا الجيل المدلل والغير صبور مثل ما كنا
بنقول نحاول مثلا نسمعن عنجد نحاول نقدر
الصعوبات
والمشاعرهم وصعوبات اللي عم بيمر فيها
ساعات بنقدر ناخد بايدهن بشكل يعني مريح
اكثر لهم لحتى يعرفوا طريقهم بالحياه طبعا
ما بتتصوروا قديش كلكم عندكم فكره اكيد
قديش الاطفال والمراهقين خاصه بحاجه لشخص
يسمعون ويتعاطف معهم وحتى اذا بدكم يعلمون
التعاطف ليش لانه هن كبروا بفتره كبروا
عاشوا بفتره الازمه لالسه جدا كانت على
بلدنا وفي منهم فقد الامل وفي منهن فات
كمان اشخاص كثير بيحبهم
مين بيعرف يمكن لو تعاطفت مع طلابي حطيت
حالي محل لون كنت حسيت بشعورهم كنت حسيت
بشعورهم وعرفت انه هن طلاب سنه تخرج
وخايفين ما يفهموا الماده
ويمكن لو هن نتعاطفوا معي كانوا ساعتها
قدروا مشاعري والشيء اللي فيه مساعدها
كانوا وكانت راح تكون انا اكيد اقل توتر
واكثر رغبه اني انا اعطي المعلومه من قلبي
اكثر واكثر بس ساعتها ما كنت رح كون واقفه
قدامكم هلا عم بحكي عن معاناتي من الصور
النمطيه على منصه
طبعا بعد كل هالمعلومات اللي نحن حكيناها
هلا وكل هالسلبيات والايجابيات صرنا
متاكدين انه مستحيل مثل ما مستحيل يكون
مجتمع متماسك مهما طال الزمن اذا كان مبني
على النمطيه كمان صرنا متاكدين انه مستحيل
يكون مستحيل ينهدم مجتمع مهما طال الزمن
اذا كان مبني على التعاطف
هلا بعد كل هالحكي اللي حكيناه سوا
صار دوركم انتم
شو راح تختار هلا نمطيه او راح تختار
التعاطف شكرا
[تصفيق]